I'm going to be telling us about
designing astronomical projects for real
fun discovery good thank you I really
enjoyed this meeting I look I really
really like meeting going to meetings
that are outside my field and it's gonna
be obvious I'm outside my field because
I'm gonna say all sorts of things about
decisions that I don't really know most
people in this room know I'm more of a
decision making than I do
just a few I should just put some names
up the two names in bold are the people
who are kind of a most relying on here
but the this the stuff I'm going to talk
about is pretty philosophical so a lot
of people contributed to it so this is
really not complete Bloom's name will
appear later good I'm just I'm just
gonna try to start conversation I
thought this is a workshop that supposed
to create some discussion so I'm gonna
try and start some discussion and I will
be trying not to be uncontroversial and
I I literally did not put a single image
into this talk I'm an astronomer and
there's no image at all so I think you
can google the things that are written
in the titles of the slides if you want
to picture the Kepler mission google it
okay good I'm gonna talk about I'm gonna
start off with some conversation about
exoplanets because it's a place where a
real-time decision-making is really
important and it's gonna be something
that is very important in the next
decade of big projects there are six
methods for finding planets around other
stars and I'm not going to talk about
them there's two methods that I am gonna
talk about one is transits which has
found thousands of planets and the other
is radial velocities which has found
hundreds of planets I have a but not for
long there because very soon Gaia will
come in and kill everybody and Gaia will
get tens of thousands of planets but
that won't be for a couple of years at
this point something like three years so
what is it transit an exoplanet transit
is when because of very good luck
because an orbit is aligned with our
line of
right the planet comes between its host
star and us and we see it because it
dims out part of the light so so if you
imagine an observer who's in the right
place looking back at the solar system
the earth every 365 point to five days
blocks out a little bit of the light of
the Sun because it passes in front of
the the face of the Sun and they're very
simple there's another sort of leading
method for finding planets and as I said
well I'm gonna say a little more about
planets that have been found by chance
their leading way to find planets is the
radial velocity method and here the idea
is because the the planet and the star
in the gravitational orbit the planet
and the star orbiting a common center of
mass and we look for the variable
Doppler shift of the star so the center
of the mass of the Sun or the center of
mass of the solar system is actually
inside the Sun but it's not at the
center of the Sun so as the planets
orbit the Sun the Sun is moving with
respect to that very center and the
important numbers here are that
jupiter-like planets produce
meter-per-second signals and earth-like
planets produce centimeter per second
signals meter per second is pretty
amazing when you think about measuring
that kind of stuff and I'm not gonna
talk about measuring I'm really just
gonna talk about decision making there's
so much beautiful stuff about all these
measurements and how they were made and
I'm basically not going to talk about
that the the imagination that's capable
that's responsible for finding the
thousands of planets by the transit
method is basically the Kepler mission
there's a bunch found by kuroh and by
also by later versions of the Kepler
mission but the the big one is the
Kepler mission and the Kepler mission is
a 42 CCD camera that just stared at one
patch of the sky for four years that's
all it did and it was designed with
exact and this is very relevant to her
we're gonna talk about in a minute it
was designed with exactly one purpose
and that's it it was designed to find
earth-like exoplanets and all the trades
when I say trades I mean all the the
things where they decide should we do
this kind of detector or that kind of
detector should we put more CCDs or
fewer CC bees all those trades were made
for the simplicity and stability of the
so that it would find earth-like
exoplanets no other science goals were
considered in its design it's very very
limited goal and it delivered way more
planets than people expected people
expected hundreds of planets to produce
thousands of planets and it also did
amazing science with stars that was not
planned for but all worked very
beautifully and there's a there's a
beautiful story about open science and
everything that we were just talking
about which I'm not going to talk about
now transits are a very blunt tool when
when you see a transiting planet you
don't learn that much about the
planetary system you learn the period
because you see a periodic dimming of
the star so you learn the period and you
learn a radius ratio the ratio between
the star and the planet and oddly you
learn the density of the star which it's
very interesting why you get the density
there's a beautiful thing in physics
which is that frequencies are density if
you have gravitational physics
frequencies or densities so we often
know the densities of objects much more
precisely than anything else for
instance we know the density of the
universe very precisely why because the
Hubble rate is a density so anyway in
the transiting case we basically just
learn the stellar density which is a
little odd and we get no information
really about the orbit beyond that we
don't get any eccentricity or anything
like that and the signal is unbelievably
sparse and this is problematic
observational ii and when you think
about if you wanted to make a really
adaptive system to find transits there's
a lot of trouble because the system is
so sparse the sun transit the earth
transits the sun for 13 hours every
365.25 days so that is very your you
have to be very lucky to observe it
because you have to be aligned with the
orbit and have to be very persistent to
observe it because you have to stare
with good time resolution continuously
so transits really are terrible radial
velocity is you get a lot more
information out of radial velocity
experiments and typically the way radial
velocity experiments work is that you
have many nights per year on a very
expensive telescope this is on the
ground now the Kepler of course was in
space its
NASA mission but typically the extreme
precision surveys are done on the ground
and you measure Doppler shifts for a few
stars every night and the key thing
about these surveys is because there's
data starved they can only do a few
stars on a few nights a year they don't
want to waste time on stars that won't
produce planets so people operating
these surveys tend to make very harsh
decisions so if a star looks like it's
very noisy they drop it if it looks like
it's not showing any signs of planets
they drop it if it looks like it's in
some kind of binary which would make it
hard to extinguish the planets they drop
it there's lots of harsh decisions made
and those decisions are made based on
the Stars past data which is very
problematic and no one to this point has
ever fully automated these decisions
that's very critical for what I'm going
to say actually you know this meeting
was a is is about real-time
decision-making for me I want to take it
up one more level and I want to but
automated decision making because
real-time decision made ain't making
done by humans is very different if from
a point of view of data analysis from
real-time decisions made by computers
they're very different and I'll try to
give a sense of that although I won't
quite spell it out as much as I'd like
to because I haven't figured it out so I
can't say this enough we say this
endlessly in my group this is the big
problem we're always encountering we're
working with datasets we're trying to
build probabilistic models of datasets
that were created by humans and we
cannot model the what the humans did
inside those shitty conference rooms
it is enraging that even though hundreds
of millions of dollars have been spent
on radial velocity experiments we have
no idea in detail why each observation
was taken and that is problematic so
from my perspective right now there's
lots of interesting things to do with
exoplanets they're unbelievable they're
very good tools there are brand new
class of astrophysics Astrophysical
objects like no one had seen a planet
around another star
ten years well 15 years ago now we know
thousands so their new class of objects
of course we're interested in finding
understanding how our own solar system
worked there's a lot of interesting
things to do at exoplanets I'm focusing
and I'll talk a little bit in this talk
about the problem of how do you find out
the properties of the whole population
of planets so that the surveys I just
talked about the Kepler and radiosity
surveys they're very focused on
discovering exoplanets but now new
exoplanets individually are not that
interesting it's much more interesting
now to ask what's the population the
high populations whole how do and what
does that tell us about how planets form
and how planetary systems evolved and
what planetary systems are stable and
what kinds of stars produce what kinds
of planets and so on and there are very
complex selection effects now radial
velocity experiments should be critical
for understanding exoplanet populations
but in fact they are not currently being
used in population inferences and the
reason is that they have humans in the
loop and we don't know how to model the
humans it's hard enough to model all of
these selection effects it is impossible
to model the humans
well maybe not impossible hard by the
way if you're not an astronomer and you
are not following this world I want you
to remember three things about planets
this is the only thing you need to
remember for my talk if you're not an
astronomer and has nothing to do with
the main point of my talk but it's more
interesting than a variant of dogma
which is that there are more planets
than stars that is now very well
established I can't say that all stars
have planets well one of the things
that's very interesting about the
statistics of planets is it's much
easier to say how many planets there are
per star than how many stars have
planets and it has to do with the fact
that the if you have to be lucky in
order to get them so because of that
luck aspect we don't know which stars
don't have planets but we do know how
many planets there are out there and
there are more planets than stars
the other thing next thing is super
somany Neptune's so things in the radius
range between
earth and Neptune are them by far not
just slightly they are by far the most
common kinds of planets and there are no
such planets in our solar system and
then thirdly the solar system is not
really typical although it's not clear
yet just how a typical it is but
certainly it doesn't have it has eight
planets in it none of which are in this
in this most common category good so my
one of my main points is that humans are
unbelievably good at finding planets but
they're very bad tomorrow very hard to
model quantitatively and so we right now
if you if you if you just sort of
naively try to use the radio velocity
data presuming that the humans were just
somehow trivially rational you will get
wrong answers and there's another
problem is that humans don't like to
waste time on control samples which is a
very big problem which I'm not really
gonna address but it's very much part of
the same situation but to be absolutely
fair I'm not sure that the time
allocation committee's would have given
the astronomers telescope time if they
had done what I'm about to ask them to
do so okay so we did this in the dark
energy yes survey for supernovae
yeah yeah I did you put in control
samples good I'm gonna talk about
cosmology in a second yeah so one of
course the major biases is that we like
to stare at something that we can get
good data mm-hm and and so this bias is
where we look yeah sorry outside the
exact they have that yeah so for the
first time yeah we wrote a code that
says this is the object you will take a
spectrum of tonight yeah yeah good
congratulations
use like we also said let's take spectra
of things that we know are things that
were not interested yeah come on yeah
and and so by the way of course nobody
mentioned this to any of the tax but
argit's I'm like oh ma I'm sorry not to
waste 10% of our yeah yeah hey thank you
Sam
have you heard of anybody else being
astronomy just putting in a control say
yes yeah there are [ __ ] there are
definitely successful proposals with big
glass that involve control samples in
fact even in radio velocity exoplanets
is starting to happen so how their
commutes in for instance at Caltech
certainly has some control objects on
but and but it's very field dependent
and right now like we've had we've had
proposals rejected ESO because they
wouldn't be as efficient at finding
planets as other proposals and we're
like like you have to be inefficient if
you want to do statistics yes so if I
post the question show me a random star
you know what what's the framework you
need for answering that good that's it
that is that's off-topic good so I'm not
gonna answer that exactly but it's very
similar so in in medical inference when
you're doing medical inference and you
can't do a controlled experiment so
you're trying to figure out whether
people taking over-the-counter medicine
is helping with their colds you and you
don't have the opportunity to a
controlled experiment you what you do is
you try to build very very closely
matched samples of people who did and
did not take the cold medicine with
attributes exactly and so that's how we
can when when we've constructed the best
control samples as we can it's that we
take all the attributes which we believe
believe could be confounding and we
match on all confounding things and then
use those as controls so we don't just
take random stars out of the urn we take
very carefully stars that match the
stars that are in our names
okay good I'm being negative I don't
want to be negative the exoplanet
revolution has been unbelievable and the
radial velocity contributions to it have
been incredible I mean what we know
about exoplanets is unbelievable given
what like we know things about spin
orbit alignments we know things about
dynamical stability receive planetary
systems and also - resonances I mean
it's ridiculous okay good I'm gonna
switch gears now that that's gonna come
back these are I'm gonna set context
with a few different examples and then
believe somehow they'll be related Sloan
Digital Sky Survey so the Sloan Digital
Sky Survey was the first really big
University based astronomy project if
you are under the age of 30 you believe
this is how astronomy works and if
you're over the age of 50 you can't
believe why anybody's wasting their time
with things like this because it's a bit
ageist for me to say but but I'm right
on the cusp here where I was involved in
this but I was also very suspicious
about why we were doing this because it
was crazy
we took imaging of a quarter of the sky
in five pass bands we took spectra of a
million galaxies and quasars and the
whole point of the survey was to measure
the growth of structure in the universe
so there's a very specific and rigid
physical model for cosmology that where
the universe starts in a homogeneous
state and then structure grows and the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey was designed to
measure that growth of structure and all
of the survey was baked in as rules for
the survey right from the beginning that
everything would be operationally
algorithmic and repeatable everything
had to be repeatable we did violate this
in a few ways but we tried not to all
violations of that were rule violations
and it was literally designed with this
long term statistical value as as a core
principle of the project it was
unbelievably over designed the imaging
was far deeper than it needed to be to
target the spectroscopy we could have
saved a factor of hundreds in observing
time because we took images that were
way too deep this spectroscopy was
higher signal-to-noise than it needed to
be we now know we can get red shows with
signals noise of one per pixel so we
could have gotten we could have done the
whole Sloan Digital Sky
in like three months and still achieve
the large-scale structure goals however
those weren't the most important papers
in fact the project was produced
something like ten I think it's just
under ten thousand papers so this year
yeah it's it's ridiculous and and then
it also led to these legs of these
subsequent surveys that use the same
hardware to do new science and these are
also producing thousands of papers so it
is absolutely productive
it was extremely over budget but it was
extremely proud and even though it went
over-budget by a factor of something
like fourteen depending on how you count
it it was more productive than anyone
expected by a factor of more than
fourteen so actually we there was a win
in the end now one thing I can also now
branch off here and go off on this
because one of the interesting things is
if the but if the project had been
budgeted accurately from the outset it
would never have been launched so
there's a very interesting question
about honesty and budgeting and and of
course the decayed 'el surveys in
astronomy every year or worried about
this problem and it's a very hard
problem because at some level we do have
to dream but in another level we have to
know what we're getting into anyway it's
complicated
one of the reasons that we didn't all
end up in jail is that there were
university partners and the university
partners many of whom were private
universities were able to complete the
project I at the time worked for the
Institute for an Institute for Advanced
Study which was one of the university
partners good so what do I conclude from
all this I don't know these are very
tentative conclusions first thing is
Jesus did not get everything right I'm
not claiming that SDSS was perfectly
designed project in fact it was kind of
a mess in various ways but it was
operationally algorithmic and the over
design meant that there was tons of
additional unplanned discovery space so
when you look at the ten thousand papers
from Sloan they're not primarily about
the growth of structure in the universe
that's not what they're primarily about
that we discovered families of asteroids
we discovered new classes of variable
stars we we found we were able to do
kinematics of the Milky Way halo we
found ultra fade galaxies are being
disrupted we I mean ridiculous things
and really this and really it's this
inefficiency that the survey was over
designed produced a lot of its success
it was most of the cost overrun software
know most the cost overrun was was
failure to start so various subsystems
weren't working and so then the marching
army had to live for another year and
another year in another year so that was
I would say that was probably
three-quarters of the overrun and then
some of the over one was just
straight-up unreal and lack of realism
about 35 CCDs and and filters and
telescope control but it is true that
the software did cost more than they
thought and one of the things one of the
legacies that's actually of Sloan
there's many legacies of Sloan and I'm
not going to talk about the but but the
one of them is that now projects in
astronomy do have software budgets and
that's you know there's still too small
but they're not zero good so present-day
cosmology experiments are much are at a
different place now partly because and
this is a little hard to get across if
you're not an astronomer but cosmology
is extremely mature field it's it's
almost as mature as high-energy physics
there's a very very rigid model with a
small number of free parameters that
explains a very large fraction of the
data and so a lot of the questions are
very mature questions about about
measuring particular parameters or
combinations of parameters and those and
and we are required by our funding
partners whether our funding partners
our universities or foundations or
agencies to show that we're making an
efficient project to meet our goals and
that efficiency could be disastrous what
does this have to do with real-time
decision making nothing but it does have
something to do with decision make
and that's gonna come up into the next
thread we're about to change topics
again and but just before we change
topics let me just say that it's very
when you're doing parameter estimation
in a rigid model you have this rigid
model like the the standard model of
particle physics and you want to know
now you know the Higgs is there now you
just want to measure the mass of the
Higgs so if your only goal is to measure
the mass of the Higgs there's just a
very well-defined set of things you're
gonna do and you know how to say which
experiment is better than which because
you can just measure the Fisher
information you have on the Higgs and it
is extremely easy to kind of
quantitatively say which design gets you
the best measurement but we don't know
how to quantitatively say what project
gets the most discovery plate space and
this came out yesterday the LHC is
designed to have tons of discovery space
it's also over designed it's over
designed for 125 GeV Higgs and it's over
designed why because maybe we'll find
new physics but it's hard to be
quantitative about this unplanned
discovery space and I'd like to and now
I do the analogies of testing in schools
when we complain about testing in
schools why not because we don't think
we should be evaluating teaching
obviously we should be evaluating
teaching the problem is that when we do
testing in schools we test the things we
can test and we don't know how to test
the things we really think are important
there's no school test for creativity
for synthesis for bringing down the
capitalist patriarchy okay switch gears
again which i think is what we all want
for our children and certainly it's what
I want good 50 years again so I want to
talk a little bit about astrometry net
basically because astrometry dotnet is
one of the projects I'm most proud of in
my career and this is what it does you
give it an image of the night sky and
that image could be something you took
with a mobile phone camera or it could
be something that's a scientific image
or it could be something from a webcam
or or so people have used this for
telescopes or it could be a historical
image like an image from a plate archive
or whatever some image that you just
don't know the provenance of and one
thing I could say is a little bit of
background here is that Harvard plate
archive for instance has millions and
millions of gold glass plates
and many of them are misfiled so they
actually don't know which plate for for
some five to ten percent of their plates
they don't know what's the pointing of
that plate so how do they figure out
which part of the sky is this plate so
that's that was one of our motivating
examples there's a bunch of other
motivating examples for this project it
now has thousand has yet tens of
thousands of users actually this project
has been very successful so this was the
first ever image reliable image
recognition system it takes that image
figures out where it is on a sky and how
big it is what orientation and and of
course labels the objects in it and all
that stuff it was the first ever
reliable image recognition system any
domain and of course we didn't get rich
the project is so this is Dustin Lang
who is talk about full stack you know
people talk about in data science what's
where's somebody who's full stack Dustin
Lang is the example of somebody who's a
full stack data scientist here are the
components that s trauma tree that
needed to work first of all it has to
automatically detect stars and
background in arbitrary imaging so I
don't care whether it's a Galaxy image
or a webcam we have to be able to find
the stars reliably in there and centroid
them that alone is something that
deserves a Nobel Prize then and and I
should say there Mike Blanton at NYU did
a lot of stuff for us then what we do is
we look up geometric hashes we came up
with clever geometric hashes for figures
of stars then you have to look up
geometric hashes that you have in your
image against the database of every
geometric hash you could possibly make
on the sky which is combinatoric lee
large so we have a comet Oracle II large
database lookup and so we had to build
the fastest KT tree in the world that
was done by kiermaier Lee who wasn't on
my original list but he's a genius that
was an undergrad working with us and
when Dustin was at sprout student
cassia's like what is being hashed huh
mmm it's so you take if you take a
figure of n stars so and and the code
can work with ant any end but we usually
work at four it turns out four is a very
good number to work at so you have four
stars here in your image you've just
chosen four of your stars and now what
we want to do is write a this real
number descriptor of this object such
that we can look it up in a database and
the way that works is we use the most
widely separated pair to establish a
coordinate system and we ask what are
the coordinates of the other two stars
in that coordinate system and the and
this this hash has some really beautiful
properties it's four dimensional right
because there's two two-dimensional
positions but those four dimensional
objects fill a four dimensional hyper
sphere well the interior of a five
dimensional whatever in three
dimensional hybrid anyway whatever it is
and they hope they fill that uniformly
so we so that one of the reasons we have
the fastest KD tree in the world is that
we have a very beautiful hash that is
very uniformly fills its space so we
were able to use a lot of geometry under
the hood so that our KD tree as though
it was it was in 2010 the fastest KD
tree in the world it was under extremely
severe circumstances good then once we
find matches in this database those are
only hypotheses so then we use Bayesian
inference to put probabilities over
those hypotheses for what the image
pointing must be and then we did
explicit decision theory using a utility
and looking at expected utility over
posteriors over hypotheses talk about
full stack this is one paper this is one
chapter of does the blanks pieces and
then it automatically visualizes the
results
everything's open source of course and
if you go to astrometry dotnet you can
get the code and also see a tutorial and
see our users and all this there's also
an astrology there's also some
there's some community there you can see
other people's images as they're going
into the system and you can play with it
yeah various people of that so there's
the gum spot positioning system which is
you know on the streets of New York
there's little black spots on the on the
sidewalk those black spots are where
people spat out gum and I got dirt on it
and each one is this unique pattern
there's also there's a visible is a
project there's certain kinds of reef
sharks that have certain patterns on
their sides so no one really used
astrometry net directly in these other
applications but the geometric hashing
ideas did propagate into some other
areas like those lights you see on a
night flight somewhere somewhere between
Nebraska oh yeah I bought them but
anyway we thought a lot about other
kinds of systems like recognizing
buildings there's a lot of architectural
features you could use there's maps if
you look down on the ground you should
be able to take a bit of a map and do
but we haven't actually gone into those
areas by the way this kind of this kind
of system is not favored like what are
the current winning things in image
recognition these days they're all
convolutional neural networks
accomplished women are allowed to win
everything now and one thing we've never
asked is whether or not we could beat
this with a convolutional neural network
and I hereby for bloom dinner at Chez
Panisse
if you can eat even if you get one
percent of our performance with a
convolutional neural network although we
might have to negotiate with a third
party to Train it there's no training
that's the thing this is not a train
system it's an expert system so we built
there's this immense database of
geometric hashes which are based on
cataloged stars in fact the system
currently runs on the gaia catalog
yes so for diet we were using the US and
OB astrometric catalogs and and there's
a lot of very there's a lot of stuff
that goes into building this database
because you actually don't want to build
arbitrary quads of stars you want to
build quads of stars that are co visible
so meaning an image is likely to have
all of those stars in it so that we did
all sorts of brightness slices and and
then we made catalogs that are more
likely to work well with ultraviolet
images and ones that are more likely to
work with infrared images and there's a
lot of engineering like just this line
alone involves a lot of engineering this
projects just ridiculous
I mean if you're right starting an
engineering company you need to hire
Dustin Lang good one thing I just want
to focus on because it is relevant for
this audience is that when so stronger
garnett only receives probabilistic
information about pointing rotation
scale right we do this database lookup
but that only gives us hypotheses and
then we put posterior probabilities on
those hypotheses using a likelihood
function that's about the stars and the
image that weren't in the hash that
generated the hypothesis so we hold out
the hypothesis the hash and then we do a
probabilistic question on the remaining
stars but we have to decide what to say
to the user do we say to the user yes
we've got your solution or do we say no
we don't know and to make that decision
we didn't want to just do it on the
balance of probabilities but as we did
on balance of probabilities around half
the time we'd be sending [ __ ] and
astronomers are not happy to get wrong
answers so it relates to the discussion
yesterday about five Sigma that came up
in the LHC conversation why is that LHC
at five Sigma that could be recast as a
decision theory question about what's
your utility so we judged that we had to
maintain our reputation that that if we
gave bad answers we would lose long-term
customers we might satisfy short-term
customers but lose long-term customers
so we actually explicitly used Bayesian
decision theory there's a table of money
amounts in this paper and I think we're
the only people in astronomy who have
explicitly given a
a function in dollars even the dark
energy task force didn't do that good so
how did we make that how do we do this
we we have to ask we had to think about
our community it's kind of like how does
a company decide what to charge for its
product it's actually a very similar
it's a very related question to how a
company decides how much to charge
especially for an intangible product
like if you I don't know if you host on
WordPress they charge you $13 a year or
whatever and like how did they get that
13 dollars number and it has something
to do with trust and reputation and how
it propagates and how do we value
different kinds of users which users do
we want and we did want users who are
conservative and wanted reliability and
we believe that reputations go bad
easily like in the early days of Sloan
we did a data release that wasn't so
good and it really hurt our reputation
as a survey and we had to rebuild that
reputation over many years so we used
all that information to make a a utility
function in the end of course we just
made it up because and I'm gonna tell
you why we had to make it up in just a
second it is very hard to make a utility
function and this is in a domain of
absolutely no consequence if you go into
domain of consequence we were hearing
about self-driving cars yesterday and
today then you really have to think
about what your utility function is this
is really non-trivial you can't just
just sit your Bayesian Tower and say hey
it's a highly probable that's a stop
sign so one thing about when we were
working on astrometry dotnet I spent a
month at Google I was just for
complicated reasons but basically I was
just working on a scientific project
which somebody who happened to be at
Google so I went to Google and I worked
at Google for a month and when I was at
Google I learned that Google has a
single objective function that it tries
to optimize which is long-term future
discounted free cash flow and that is
the objective every one of us in this
room should optimize in every decision
we make in all of our lives
whether you're going to buy a coffee at
strata where the obvious optimum is
don't buy that or choosing who you're
gonna live the rest of your life with
you should be thinking long-term future
discounted free cash flow and what is
this what is this thing why is this the
thing but it is the thing and you will
you'll think you're think this is
ridiculous and then you don't think
about it sleep now you wake up in the
middle and I go oh damn it
the reason first of all its long-term
future because in the long run all you
really care about is the long run you're
willing to take some short-term pain
long-term you want to be successful so
it's long-term and unfortunately
long-term is the killer because in the
the literally the definition of
long-term if you take microeconomics
what's the definition of long-term the
long term is the time scale over which
everything's variable so you don't have
a good model of the world for the long
term
we don't know what astronomy is gonna be
like in 15 years like 15 years would be
pretty long-term for astronomy because
lots of things change new classes of
objects get discovered new telescopes
get built new meteors hit facilities new
Wars bomb out telescope observatories
and so on certain discounted there's a
discount rate and you prefer to get your
cash now than to get it later
and the discount rate is different for
different people my discount rate is a
lot lower than a graduate students
discount rate and the graduate students
discount rate drops to VIP or becomes
very high right as they are entering the
job market and then why is it free cash
flow it's current revenue less current
expenses free cash flow is very similar
profit but it's not the same as profit
because it does you're not allowed to
count against that long term
expenditures that grow your company
because those are the reasons we're
doing these things well you are doing
your astronomy to get your long term
capabilities improved okay good
this is the thing that we need to have a
model of if we are going to automate
decision making that's my position now I
now of course the fact that yeah here I
just say the fact that the objective is
exclusively long term means you'll never
have a precise estimate
your lawns of this utility and if you go
into companies and look at the situation
like if you look at Google they were
explicitly optimizing this thing but
then they would talk about it in
heuristic terms they did not have a
quantitative model for it even though it
was their explicit objective but I think
we will be able to make proxies for this
in astronomy and we should and I'm
working on that now actually the
discount rate is a strong function of
courier stage constant benefit oh this
is an important thing
scientific papers have values that are
in the hundreds of thousands of dollars
and it a lot of astronomers don't lose
sight of this like I know people who are
like they don't want to send their
graduate students to a conference and
I'm like because it's too expensive it's
like 3,000 bucks or whatever I'm like do
you realize the paper that writing is
costing you 125 thousand dollars it
really doesn't matter what they're not
used under this conference and in the
way I get this number is by just doing
full cost accounting just do full cost
accounting a typical paper that I write
has 5 people on it they've worked on it
for months they are all reasonably
well-paid white-collar workers and we
also use some facilities if you used if
you used a few nights of tech time
you've got it right there and one last
point is it is pointless to compute this
in any units except exchangeable
currency and the reason is you have to
make trades between qualitatively
different things you have to decide are
we going to hire somebody else or are we
going to buy another CCD you have to be
able to make those trades and so those
have different costs and they also have
different benefits in terms of your
utility and you can only make the trades
if it's in dollars I put Bitcoin up
there for Josh's benefit that's not his
only contribution to this time good what
are the implications for this meeting we
need to build utility models our utility
models need to explicitly look towards
the long term the end goals so we need
to be building utility models that are
thinking about publications future grant
funding junior scientist careers those
are our objectives yeah
include the opportunity cost of not
doing of course you have to include
opportunity cost and that's actually
when I was at Google another thing they
said at Google in public meetings was
their biggest see they always said and
they probably still do that their
biggest single cost is opportunity cost
that they're not doing things that they
could be doing given the smart people
that are in the room and I believe me I
think about that a lot for my own
personal career because like right now
we're just starting stss five if I get
into stss five there's a bunch of things
other things I can't do and that's a big
opportunity cost so stss five has to be
a kick-ass project for me to do it I can
see how you could eventually model all
the things that are within you're not
gonna do that's an infinite space
exactly that's I guess you could say
that is another reason this is
incomputable although I actually think
it's the same reason as the long-term
reason because those opportunities are
really about long-term losses cuz on
short timescales you could always switch
what you're doing yeah I I'm talking
like this I'm talking like this but I'm
not gonna answer those questions yeah so
in this in this economic model where
does the notion of competition of fit I
mean what what sort of what notion of
agencies with with in indivisible self
interests come I don't really have a
theory about that
but um and of course I sometimes when I
talk about this stuff I talk about it at
the community level so I'm about to go
there so I'm actually in a few slides
I'm gonna be talking about the the
long-term future discounted free cash
flow of the whole astronomical community
so I I always think about astronomy very
cooperatively but you know certainly
some sub branches of astronomy think of
it very competitively but then I would
just sweep it in to these kinds of
questions so I'm not thinking of it as a
game if that's where you're we are you
thinking yeah I'm not thinking about it
as a game I'm thinking
right yeah good and then it's probably
as useful to think of it as a game but I
am NOT I'm explicitly not and I'm a very
much a believer that the Astronomy
community is working together which you
know you can observational II you could
argue about that
yeah more soft parameters here so how
much people like doing up for example
there's some things do you include yeah
good I haven't really thought about that
it's and but I do often find myself
advising people to work on things that
they love because they're gonna do them
better but I write it could go into any
of these things I mean you're much more
likely to have career success if you
love doing astronomy then if you hate it
but you know some people have survived
the job market hating astronomy yeah
yeah exactly so yeah I'm not going to
ever write down an explicit equation
because I can't so I'm a mess here this
is really pure bull this is one full
hour of [ __ ] usually usually at
workshops like this I'm limited to 20
minutes of good let me just make a very
very small scale comment let's go just
to a really trivial thing you're just
gonna write a paper where you say I've
discovered a new planet or I can rule
out Monde or something you're writing
some paper which just said with some
very straightforward scientific result
just writing this in your abstract is a
decision it is a decision that one model
is more of is better than another now
the way hard-core Bayesian tend to think
about this and I'm pretty hardcore
Bayesian but one of the ways Bayesian
sin to think about this is that you do
marginalize likelihoods you compare
marginalize likelihoods you want to
fully marginalize and then ask questions
about the Margot's like leads are
marginalized posterior probabilities you
want to think about model probabilities
but I'm explicitly saying that that is
wrong that is not the right way you
cannot make
decision that way but those are
probabilities they're not decisions
their probabilities probabilities are
not decisions and it's very important
not to confuse these things the other
thing is these integrals that you need
to do who are hella expensive we've
burned so much CPU time doing
marginalize likelihoods you really have
to be integrating utilities over your
parameters within your models that's
what you need to be integrating and
notice I just mentioned that you don't
know those utilities precisely so if
you're burning tons of CPU time to
compute an integral that isn't actually
the integral you're supposed to be
computing you're probably making a
mistake and that's a very
straightforward consequence of all this
and I think it's undeniable I'm actually
Jane's the the by the Bayesian Bible
chains makes this point explicitly but
people don't usually read that far in
switch gears again okay this is blooms
slide blooms joke that we should maybe
have star bucks which is a currency that
we trade among astronomical facilities
or assets so imagine we have a hetero
G's network of astronomical resources
now I'm I'm meta up into community level
the community does have what am i one of
the things I like to say in a different
talk that I give is that even though
individual astronomers might be
frequentist or Bayesian the whole
astronomical community because it's a
rational actor is the whole community or
quasi rational actor is pretty Bayesian
like publications that are produced in
astronomy are kind of distributed over
hypotheses with about the probabilities
that we hold them to be correct and and
the community as a whole in some sense
is trading some kind of currency for
resources but we I'm just arguing we
should make this explicit and one of the
nice things is if you were able to make
this explicit then you could objectively
well not objectively not objectively is
a bad word here everything's subjective
in this talk utilities subjective
probabilities are subjective everything
so forget that
so cross out that word
but you could optimally apportion
resources in principle so it's it's
hilarious I gave a talk here a month ago
and chatted with some people and they
suggested that and we are actually doing
guys
with the sed machine ICD machine a great
example so if you're not an astronomer
so LSST is going to produce enormous
numbers of alerts like tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of lure tonight
there's gonna be various facilities that
are very relatively low costs that are
gonna fall up as many as they can none
of them can follow up a hundred thousand
moeslem Kavala tens a night so
decision-making has to take place this
is and having an explicit you tell great
so ok so it's quite interesting so the
unit of buck is called the SRK yeah
that's a TL a yes was we assigned a unit
for each observing 15-minute observing
sequence during the night so there X
don't have units over the year yeah
and then there is a weighting factor
depending upon which group is triggering
one so we value certain triggers because
their rear died yeah or and that's and
that's how that set up this currency
Chavez and you're a portion and you can
trade yeah exactly
humans are great at this so humans are
great at trading currency now I'm just
suggesting we need to make the assets
trade the currency directly yeah in
terms of currency couple of the data
about citation no because you might you
might be willing negative station
well for instance it really you in
that's too short term you want to be
thinking long term long term I want to
rule astronomy so individual citations
I might even sacrifice citations in
order to get long term control over all
assets
what else was I gonna say oh yeah and
probably would look like a live auction
or a market so so now I want to just go
to global telescope networks just I just
want to come step back from that okay
that's crazy talk and it's [ __ ] but
let's talk about some things that are
very real so one is there's all these
global telescope networks out there and
there's they're beautiful and they allow
you to do things like do 24-hour
observing even though the Earth's
rotating because you have observatories
all over the earth and there's some and
the amazing thing is some are operated
by amateurs there's this great
microlensing collaboration that's
largely amateurs and there's the aavso
which does variable star observing
there's a lot of really beautiful
networks that are that are global and
there's a lot of focus on making sure
that the nodes and the network are as
similar as possible and the data are as
uniform as possible
this is pessimal we should not be doing
that if you're not an astronomer
pessimal is the opposite of optimal for
instance when you're running a company
do you try to hire employees that are as
identical as possible yes some people do
but they're not the employers that are a
good representation of what we want to
do in astronomy and one of the reasons
there's a lot of reasons people try to
make things as homogeneous as possible
but the main one is not a legitimate
reason and that's simplicity it's not
legitimate for us to ask that our data
analysis be simple that's not a
legitimate request we should be asking
for a gain analysis to be as informative
as possible or for us to learn the most
shouldn't be it's not simplicity that
we're shooting for it's knowledge that
we're shooting for or it's long-term
future discounted free cash flow which
is probably not measured by simplicity
but but there are there are some good
reasons that people like homogeneity one
is that there's no theory of how to make
trades I'm developing a theory about it
making button right now there's no
theory of how to make trades and the
other is that it's easier to maintain
facilities where there's a lot of
homogeneity and it's hard to maintain
heterogeneous facilities so there's it's
a lot of issues so our vision
our is unspecific hear me my vision and
but I think it's also vision of people
in this room is that we would follow up
these time-domain operations wit by
trading assets in a heterogeneous
network and then the assets should have
a utility model and some of the assets
could be humans there's no sense in
which all the assets have to be robots
but but obviously for some projects I'm
interested in all the assets have to be
robots and this is not a near-term goal
the reason it's not a near-term goal is
I don't have any of this technology
ready I just said this bla bla bla but I
wanted to point out that heterogeneity
is incredibly useful
like for instance sampling theorems
there's these sampling theorems when you
have regularly sampled data there's all
sorts of frequencies you can't see
jitter the sampling free the sampling
times a little bit and all of those
theorems clean up right now LSST is
gonna take every single exposure 30
seconds long if there's an Astrophysical
phenomena on shorter than 30 seconds
they can't see it they randomized their
exposure times they can see it it's like
just that just cyan't more science you
get to science more if you do more
heterogeneity spectral coverage same
thing the weight like why would you
always observe this guy in the same band
passes that would be insane once again
coming back to the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey I'm nearly done because here's
what I come back to each of my themes
I'm just gonna say something about even
one of them is the original plan for
Sloan was to do a single pass over the
sky of imaging and rely on the
calibration telescope to tell us what
the transparency was and just rely on
system stability to give us good
calibration that completely failed and
what we did this was with Finkbeiner and
Schlegel and Nikhil padmanaban as we
convinced the survey to do some stripes
at wrong angles so we would get the data
crossing data and that way we got we got
some stars that would see different
detector locations note heterogeneity
the same star sees different detector
locations that allowed us to tie
together
different parts of the detector and we
delivered the highest quality
calibration for the survey which is now
the standard calibration with a survey
in fact all the calibration data that
we're taking for the survey were shelved
they never got used so this tiny bit of
heterogeneity enormous ly improved what
we could do it this long survey and
that's trivial heterogeneity NASA Kepler
Kepler kept its pointing as stable as
possible so that every star is exactly
in the same place that's a great idea
because it makes the data very easy to
use but it prevented us from learning
anything about the spacecraft's
calibration and we can show that there
are limits to questions you can ask for
the data at the end because we don't
have that information we don't have a
flat field for Kepler and we can't have
one because of operationally how it
operated now now with k2 mission we're
learning a little bit about the flat
field but only a little bit good we
talked about that there and in some
white papers that we wrote everything
I've said here with substantially
complexify operations so this is comes
at a cost everything I'm saying does
have a cost so we have to do
cost-benefit again etc so this is like
the every talk there's a theme of talks
today that you have to go fractal like
this inception aspect but anyway I think
we have an obligation I think there's an
ethical obligation to do as well as we
can we can't say well we're just going
to do it because this way because it's
simpler that's just unethical we've
asking people for hundreds of millions
of dollars and even the Simons
Foundation is fundamentally money coming
from the public now of course I have to
disclose here this is my ethics slide I
have to disclose here I would benefit
enormous Lee if we switch to this mode
and finally coming back to radial
velocity experiments if we could make
progress towards specifying this utility
even some proxies then we could build
algorithmic adaptive programs that would
be just as efficient as humans are at
making decisions but would be
algorithmic so that we would be able to
pass statistical tests through those
same algorithms and if the utility we
write down is sophisticated enough it'll
even generate generate the statistical
controls naturally so we're working on
this now this is a project we're doing
right now trying to see whether or not
we could build tests follow-up campaigns
that would be algorithmic and then see
if we can get a time allocation
committee to accept one which is the
more harder problem good that's it that
my conclusion side is just the trigger
warnings that I should have given you at
the beginning thank you so just
historical point that energy is
telescope network was a thing like a
decade ago we had conferences called
yeah I remember technology is called
real time you know markup languages for
robot yeah yeah all of the tech kind of
existed and and even in the ocean
Starbucks was like chessmen and in 2006
so these ideas of what you're proposing
have been around for a while and they
never really took off I know yep
questions that I still have is is why
mm-hmm at some level it's discussing a
lot of those early papers it is not a
technological problem with the
sociological one you've hinted at that
but uh yeah given that this idea has
been around for decades why why isn't
this taking on good alright so I don't
have an answer to that but I I would say
that the more and more voices in the
radial velocity community and the radial
velocity community controls a lot of
ground-based observing now if you look
how many instruments are being built
something like 15 extreme precision
instruments are being built right
so if those all come complete a large
fraction ground-based observing will be
radial velocity and that community is
feeling a little bit of the pressure
that they're not being used
statistically and believe me we're going
to turn up the heat for the during the
decay toll survey we will really turn up
the heat and so I also think the
community is getting much more stuff is
statistically sophisticated is the
second thing and then a third thing is
related to this cosmology point so the
cosmology missions because they're so
the cosmology missions are so specific
and mature where they can really compute
exactly what they're going to produce
now in the when you think about the de
kado process that's being competed
against exoplanet people who are like
hey we're gonna find cool [ __ ]
so the exoplanet community is going to
have to come together and demonstrate
that they are going to achieve
statistical goals as well as discovery
goals and so I think that pressure
coming from the parts of astronomy that
have very well-defined things will help
but but I but I'm not really answering
your question because you could have
said all those same things going into
the last decade all survey and it didn't
happen so my optimism has been rewarded
in the past that's all I got so you
mentioned discovery but one major class
of discovery is anomaly detection right
not necessary I mean it depends just how
I get so the question is about anomaly
detection so it's some low imagine
imagine the sky every star in the sky is
not at all variable there's no variable
stars and then and you build a
calibration system for your you know you
self calibrate your data under the
assumption that every time you return to
the start is exactly the same brightness
then it turns out they are variable you
will throw off your calibration so
that's true and so in that sense in that
sense the heterogeneous Energon a
Plus bad assumptions would be bad but
heterogeneity with good assumptions is
not I think bad for anomaly detection so
let me know one way to think about true
anomaly czar mentally well write a good
and an anomaly is a bad assumption so in
that sense right so in that sense if you
say there are anomalies you're saying
that my assumptions are bad right I
think it is it is very important to
build systems such that you can detect
the unexpected as they say and what does
that look like I don't know exactly you
might well for one for one all you make
assumption and one of the things that's
wrong with the word assumption is people
have this kind of vision that once
you've made an assumption you're stuck
with it but of course all assumptions
are testable so I think it's very
important in a project like this the
more you automate the more you have to
take each assumption project your data
into the space of that assumption and so
that that assumption is correct so for
instance in we built a model of the Gaia
data where we assumed that stars are
compactly distributed on the HR diagram
and there are anomalous stars that have
no other partners near them in Gaia
there are such stars we don't understand
what they all are yet because our model
makes the fundamental assumption that
these stars must come from the compact
distribution they get drawn into the
compact distribution and put there and
but that's totally visible because you
can just go back and ask which are the
stars that the model was least happy
with and those stars do up here and then
you can see they're not it's not like
they're hidden but you do have to decide
to go look for them so I think if you
did something like this you would want
to put a lot of effort into looking at
the badly described parts of the world I
think that would be critical but it
would also be very productive
so anyway you come up with to model
utility it's always gonna be you know
there's some risk of forcing the
community into yeah absolutely yeah so
the question is about bad incentives ya
know and it's so many like these story
you know we in my group we do tons of
optimization of things like we do things
like we optimize apertures for a Templar
photometry and you write down an
objective function that you can optimize
to do photometry on this star and it
goes
there's my aperture cuz you get really
good data here it's perfectly flat
because there's no flux and it's very
easy to write down objectives that are
bad objectives so I have a lot of
reactions to that the first is you you
really have to simulate the hell out of
anything you're gonna do here before you
start and and by simulate I don't mean
with candy simulations you have to get
really realistic simulations so in fact
one of the nice things is in the radial
velocity space there's tons of data to
use to use as you could build your
simulations out of existing data that
would be very realistic simulations that
would give you a sense of what the data
are like so so one thing is you have to
seem like the hell out of things and
make sure it doesn't put you into
perverse spaces but the other thing is
many groups have to take this same
approach competitively we will need to
compete here because we will make
mistakes and we will blow telescope time
in the early days chasing bad things and
that will also happen for the supernova
or the sed machine follow-up because you
just can't have the first room time out
you're gonna make some mistakes and so
you will we would have to build this as
a set of stage projects that are staged
in a right way so that we can fail fast
abort and one of the interesting things
you know people are saying driverless
cars need to have a kill switch you know
when we put this into the the ESO tach
we're probably gonna have to say it has
a kill switch
the situation I would well you know and
I will I will put out a white paper
before the de kado survey and I'll see
if everyone in astronomy will sick of
Fanta collegian my optimization army but
my usual experience of the Astronomy
community is that they don't so really
what I'm really doing here is trying to
push the community to think in terms of
objectives I rely I'm not sure we'll
ever hit really what this but I want us
to think in terms of objectives and I
also want to think as think in terms of
being more algorithmic and less
heuristic when we take these data that's
all I would I would consider it a huge
success if we take a tiny step in those
two directions yes do you think why it
should be operating cash flow no can I
spend a long time last night try to
understand the difference between
operating cash flow and free cash flow
[ __ ] gone with it good that's good
right so so the weird thing about this
context is we would have to think of the
the income would be in intangibles we
have to put value on intangibles
so publications citations discoveries
information about so the thing that the
small-scale project we're trying to do
right now is put a utility on to
distributions over distributions of the
exoplanet population so say we build a
model of the exoplanet population as a
probability distribution over exoplanet
properties the certainty with which we
know that we might be able to turn into
a utility proxy that would help us make
these decisions but if you really want
to go to long-term free cash flow you'd
have to turn that into publications and
think about the values of publications
and so on so and since some of those
things are gonna happen in your future
not in your present you have to make
decisions before you have them so
the income part of it is exceedingly
complicated and as Josh said the cost
part of it is also complicated because
there's an opportunity cost aspect to it
as well which is you know explicitly
intangible and then how do you fold in
making that data public into that model
alright so you're kind of talking about
what my benefit is going to be because
I'm gonna derive from this but then yep
historically we share that good the
production of valuable data sets is
definitely would be counted as income in
this and so for me it's income that I
have produced the data set that other
people are using because that helps me
so that would come in to income side but
one thing that I didn't explicitly
mention that you've reminded me to
mention is one of the main points of
this is everything you have to do has to
be wide open because the whole point of
this is to be bolted to the manifold of
reproducibility you have to be
reproducible in every way because that's
the whole point that it can then be done
by in in legacy projects but yeah so
right and some astronomers would say
that if they had to give away their data
it would be a cost to them so that also
is another thing that shows you just how
subjectiveness is that's another reason
why the astronomical community as a
whole is not going to agree with my
utility function all right let's thank
David again
[Applause]